the Joe Rogan experience who do you like
for president well I just I was just
telling um Jamie that I was in I spent
New Year's in New Hampshire with Andrew
yeh and the yang gang I'm writing about
her right and I have to tell you like
I'm really not just saying this the
power of the like the what I'm calling
like the Rogen effect it was insane like
I went down the line waiting to get into
this bar was snowing outside and I just
like asked everybody how'd you hear
about Andrew yang like 80% of them was
from your podcast it was really
unbelievable um I like I like his energy
I don't know if I agree with him on like
I don't have strong views about you bi
or what he calls the freedom dividend
thousand dollars a month I don't know
what I think about that he's like
against circumcision easily know if I
agree with him on most of his things
against circumcision you don't agree
with that I know really
yeah no one cuts baby dicks I'm not like
passionate about that are you
yeah people lose their dicks a lot of
kids every year do you know children die
from that big day yes all the time
it's very common really yes like
multiple children per year lose their
penis from an unnecessary antiquated
operation where you cut off their dicks
to make it look different okay you're
cutting skin off of their dick and they
wind up getting infected and they lose
their dicks it's I mean it doesn't
happen all the time but it happens
enough time where you go this should
never happen this is a completely
unnecessary operation Robert Baker its
229 deaths per year from circumcision in
the United States bones your estimates
that apparently approximately 119 infant
boys died from circumcision related each
year in the u.s. 1.3 percent of all male
neonatal deaths from all causes
there are several case reports of death
in the medical literature yeah this it's
not simple you're cutting skin skin is
an organ you're you you have an
unnecessary
you have an unnecessary operation that
you're doing to an infant and it's
decorative mm-hmm and I had a joke Robin
we don't buy any of the studies about
how it prevents STDs and
no no I don't wash a dick I cannot
believe we're talking this should be
talking about it well why not kids are
dying like it's like how many of them
have to die before we say this is a
ancient ridiculous ritual it doesn't
make any sense
okay I've seen the arguments for and
against like that it prevents STDs like
Latino prevents STDs condoms and
abstinence that's what prevents STDs and
and in some cases vaccinations this is
what prevents STDs this circumcision is
ridiculous doesn't even makes any sense
okay cannot believe I stumbled into this
cuz I was talking about injury yay we
[ __ ] up I guess I did I didn't know
this was like a strongly held your an
int activist is that what they're yes
whatever int activist that's a good way
but I've never heard that expression but
that's exactly what I am yeah don't cut
baby dicks it's real simple you say it
that way people go yeah that sounds
gross we say Oh circumcision like oh
what a wonderful ritual and it's a
symbolic of your journey until if the
[ __ ] out of here you're cutting baby
dicks it's it doesn't make any sense I
mean it's not as disgusting as what they
do to woman's clitoris is in and so that
makes it was sensible to like yes it's a
different reason for doing it but it's
you mutilating a kid you're just doing
it in a way that it's okay like if you
cut a piece of my earlobe off I'm gonna
be alright I'm from a family of four
daughters I have not thought deeply
about I did not know that statistic you
put it up there not good yeah most
people don't know it and I've talked to
people who have had immediate family
members who have vet horrible illnesses
or injuries from circumcision it's
terrible
[Applause]